Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
reciban un cordial saludo desde París un
placer que estén nuevamente en nuestra
sintonía para este número de Carrusel de
las artes en el que iremos de la
antigüedad a la modernidad en el espacio
de este programa
el esplendor de Ramsés II El rey de los
reyes del Egipto antiguo se despliega en
una exposición histórica que se presenta
en París y que es un éxito popular
Pablo Picasso revolucionó el mundo del
arte para los 50 años de su muerte les
contaremos como Pablo se convirtió en
Picasso no en su España natal sino en la
capital francesa
y en nuestra Crónica musical iremos al
encuentro de la fama el grupo de Rock
francés saca el mercado teatro lúcido un
cuarto álbum inspirado en los ritmos
latinos y cantado completamente en
español
[Música]
París se convirtió este año en el
epicentro de la egiptología homenajeando
al faraón Ramsés II en una exposición
grandiosa en la villette una muestra
única para conocer la vida y obra de
este monarca el más longevo y poderoso
del Antiguo Egipto Ramsés y el oro de
los faraones es el nombre de esta
exposición y allí estuvo Melissa barra
[Música]
El rey de los reyes de Egipto revela
todos sus secretos en la gigantesca sala
de la vileta en París Ramsés y el oro de
los faraones expone 180 objetos
sarcófagos momias y joyas de la edad de
oro egipcia Benedicto forma parte del
equipo de egiptólogos
es El faraón de todos los superlativos
Ramsés II vivió en el siglo XIII antes
de Cristo hace 3.300 años su reinado
duró 67 años el más largo de la historia
egipcia tuvo 110 hijos en el Antiguo
Egipto no se separaba la iglesia y el
estado están entremezclados El faraón
era un dios y era quien mantenía la
mahat la organización justa del mundo
por eso para los egipcios el oro
representaba la carne de los dioses aquí
entendemos por qué todas esas máscaras
de oro o doradas que se colocaban sobre
las momias de la realeza
como un Dios en la tierra Ramsés siguió
siendo venerado mil años después de su
muerte dejó como legado proezas de
patrimonio histórico
[Música]
quien construyó el templo increíble de
abu simbel excavado en la montaña hay
dos templos el de Ramsés y el de
nefertari su esposa es el templo de la
desmesura con colosos de 20 metros una
profunda sucesión de salas cuatro
estatuas excavadas al fondo del
santuario que el sol ilumina dos veces
al año en el equinoccio para recargarlas
de luz
la ley prohíbe hoy en día que las momias
de la realeza salgan de Egipto la pieza
maestra de la exposición es el féretro
del monarca fallecido a los 92 años una
joya de Cedro libanés deslumbrante en la
sala final
este féretro tiene una historia
increíble no es original es muchísimo
más antiguo que sin duda de la época de
Tutankamón fue usado como una suerte de
féretro auxiliar para proteger a la
momia del rey que fue saqueda dos veces
se mantuvo en esa caja de madera durante
2.800 años hasta su hallazgo en 1881 la
primera vez que vino a París fue en 1976
llegó incluso con la momia que requería
cuidados debido a un deterioro causado
por los hongos desde entonces no había
vuelto entonces tenerlo aquí de nuevo es
muy emocionante
para el presidente de labilette de su
presencia es todo un honor
desde entonces no ha vuelto a salir de
Egipto es un préstamo excepcional de las
autoridades egipcias el féretro llegó en
avión en una caja llena de magia
escoltada por la guardia republicana
hasta aquí es impactante Y seremos los
únicos en verla no se exponen ningún
otro lugar está protegida por un vidrio
especial como las piezas más importantes
mantenemos cierto nivel de humedad
constante en todas las salas Es
realmente un espectáculo impresionante
se espera que Ramsés supere el récord de
la muestra Tutankamón que en 2019 trajo
un millón y medio de aficionados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en 2023 se conmemoraron los 50 años de
la muerte de Pablo Picasso el pintor
nacido en Málaga fue uno de los artistas
más extraordinarios del siglo XX pero en
París fue donde se convirtió en el genio
del arte y adoptó el nombre de Picasso
hoy mundialmente conocido
[Música]
Pablo Ruiz Picasso tenía 21 años y
cierta fama en España a principios del
siglo XX pero fue en el barrio parisino
de montmarka donde emergió el artista
fenomenal
[Música]
en 1903 Picasso decide instalarse en
París y descubrir el emblemático
batolawag un taller donde trabajaban
muchos artistas y que es único en ese
momento de la capital del arte en el
mundo es París
[Música]
Allí se vivía de forma muy precaria era
sucio pero en ese lugar había una
fraternidad de artistas donde Picasso se
sintió a gusto en esa época Picasso
pintó a la gente que vivía en las calles
a los pobres los famélicos los bohemios
los artistas es el famoso periodo Rosa y
luego azul y donde Picasso buscaba
plasmar el alma humana
París buscando la gloria e hizo todo lo
posible por alcanzarla y llegó un
momento en el que ya no le Fue
suficiente el capítulo del batolla se
terminó con el extraordinario cuadro la
señoritas de Aviñón con el que Picasso
sorprendió a todos es una pintura
cubista que desestructura la realidad es
algo inédito que nunca antes había
concebido
después de
en mi caso vivió en diferentes
direcciones en París ciudad que vio
nacer un cuadro emblemático
1937 Picasso pintó en París el Garnica
que catapultó su nombre a nivel
internacional se inspiró en la masacre
del pueblo de guernica pero en realidad
el objetivo de Picasso no era político
ni reivindicativo años después Picasso
se acercó al partido comunista Francés
pero nunca fue un resistente o defensor
de los republicanos contra el franquismo
más bien lo que quiso pintar Picasso fue
la tragedia humana
el caso vivió sus últimos años en el sur
de Francia Pero por qué abandonó París
la quité el caso dejó París en plena
Gloria pero él ya había agotado todo lo
que la capital le podía ofrecer sus
orígenes españoles se los llevaron al
sur de Francia a la costa mediterránea
allí en sus cuadros se llenaron de luz
pero es una luz Trágica
llena de sombras más bien la sombra
dentro de la luna
[Música]
y llegó la hora de la música en Carrusel
de las artes y hoy nuestra atención se
centra en un grupo francés emblemático
su cuarto disco está cantado totalmente
en español y con él han decidido
conquistar América Latina de eso nos
habla nuestra compañera Natalia
olivareszola Natalia Hola María Carolina
y él ellos son el Dúo la fam un grupo
varias veces recompensado por la
industria musical y uno de los grupos
más internacionales de la escena
francesa fuimos a ver a Marlon uno de
los dos integrantes bien dispuesto a
conquistar al público Francés pero sobre
todo al público latinoamericano con ese
disco enteramente escrito en español
teatro lúcido
Hola a todos Soy Marlon del grupo lafam
yo he creado el grupo Hace 13 años con
sashako hoy no estás allá porque
necesitaba un descanso y Mientras tanto
yo me encargo de mantener la casa
[Música]
con tantas giras tuvimos la oportunidad
de ir a España y también a latinoamérica
estuvimos en México por primera vez en
el 2014 y también fuimos a Chile a
Argentina a fuerza de ir nos impregnamos
del español y como teníamos preparadas
muchas canciones en castellano tuvimos
esta idea de hacer un disco entero en
español
[Música]
no pasa nada no pasa nada
escribieron ese disco con buses
femeninas y lo escribieron como un libro
de viaje pero sobre todo tras haber
descubierto un lugar emblemático de la
cultura y de las artes mexicana El
verdadero teatro lúcido
[Música]
tenemos las llaves del teatro lúcido es
un teatro mexicano donde se practica
mucha improvisación impregnado de
surrealismo y donde vivimos momentos
locos mágicos Wendy moira la artista que
lo creó ha realizado obras
participativas donde el público es
protagonista el objetivo es revolucionar
el teatro y hacerlo más mágico
el teatro lúcido pero también ciudades
como villarritas a la frontera Franco
española ciudades como Sevilla el
flamenco los mariachis El Paso doble y
también el reggaetón fueron unas de las
cosas que también quisieron plasmar en
ese disco el grupo la fama
[Música]
Sácate la
sácatela sácatela
nuestro ADN y Nuestro objetivo es
inspirarnos de la música antigua y
mezclarla para crear cosas nuevas desde
la música clásica la música tradicional
grupos antiguos en nuestra música está
todo el repertorio del siglo 20 swing
jazz Rock sintetizador Electro nuestra
estética se inspira en el estilo vintage
en lo Antiguo y Tratamos de convertirlo
en otras cosas etcétera
[Música]
el grupo juega con los cliché y a veces
el mal gusto como lo habrán notado pero
sin arrogancia es lo que nos subrayó
Marlon decir solamente que teatro lúcido
es el primer capítulo de un largo
proyecto que se va a llamar colección
Odisea gracias Natalia Olivares por
presentarnos ese grupo Súper conocido
aquí en Francia y con ellos vamos a
terminar este programa Carrusel de las
artes que tuvimos el gusto de
presentarles desde nuestro estudio en
París Muchísimas gracias por su sintonía
y hasta la próxima
[Música]
sácatela yo te lo digo contigo tienes
que olvidar este día para los amores del
mundo de tu pobre corazón de tu cordura
sácatela